[Musique]
implantée à saint benoît le foyer
d'accueil médicalisé les trois cascades
accueille 70 adultes atteints d'un
handicap psychique ou autres déficiences
géré par la fondation père favron afin
d'améliorer leur cadre de vie la finit
en bois de goyavier du département a
travaillé à l'embellissement du site
d'un premier temps en fait je venais
chercher ben j'ai proposé quelques
embellissement du site où ça a plu je
vais l'apprenti direction du site est
amenée à terme cet embellissement et le
but c'était sur l'embellissement du site
faire participer en fait les résidents
sur le côté embellissement rajoute t r
joue de deux des fleurs et est aussi un
petit allié ateliers participatifs
aujourd'hui sur les petits objets qu'on
fait habituel
sur les ateliers lithiques d'ailleurs
cache pots jardinières et à crayons les
résidentes également participé à un
atelier afin de réaliser divers objets
en bois de goyavier travaille beaucoup
d'intervenants extérieurs
on a des ateliers yoga musique peinture
danse indienne
donc c'est très important pour eux parce
que sa structure les journées ils ont
début ils savent que voilà ils sont
aussi dans l'utilité sociale et ça me
permet aussi d'acquérir des savoir-faire
de travailler sur des techniques
manuelles et l'objectif étant aussi que
nous sommes plutôt dans de travailler
avec le dehors donc ces personnes ne
sont pas amenés à vivre toute leur vie
au sein de notre établissement des
résidents satisfait des améliorations
apportées à leur établissement mais
surtout très fier d'y avoir contribué
je suis étonné de sa voiture d'ici
démontre piquionne de baseball québec
j'aime chez tenez suffit à prix c'est
passionnant de travailler ici mais c'est
bien je trouve qu'aujourd'hui si
confortable fauteuil ça fait des bonds
des beaux-arts pour nous c'est bien
c'est joli cv c'est ce que tu satisfait
j'ai le fauteuil bien gâchis ce bien que
le fauteuil le fauteuil en vn en bambou
y aviez les jolies il plaît à - la
recherche de la qualité dans
l'accompagnement constitue un des
piliers de l'action de la fondation père
favron faire
merci
[Musique]